aber mein name ist flug an seine lieben
zuschauer nachdem wir euch dieses video
angeschaut habt werdet ihr euch
wahrscheinlich so anfühlen für die
ärmste kirchenmaus auf dieser welt andy
reagieren heute mal wieder gemeinsam auf
rich kids of instagram
am ersten foto hat sich ein rich kind
dazu entschlossen bei mcdonald's essen
zu gehen
wir sehen schon heruntergeschrieben
sword drei pässen food also passend ist
sonne so ein ausdruck für arme bauern
damals gewesen natürlich fotografiert er
dabei seine rolex sympathischer nächsten
foto zeigt uns einen rich kit den
einzigen möglichen weg und bei einem
restaurant anzukommen
und zwar mit einem helikopter tiger ich
würde erstmal rechtschreibung lernen das
nächste ich will gar nicht wissen was da
für ein betrag unten steht weg ist
borussias team egal
das war's fünfstellig moms ethno krems
on the floor ja so was wie teller kenne
ich nicht an dem ich einfach mal meinen
imac 1 unterlagen die first birthday
tanks terry
der bekommt einen ferrari und ich zu
meinen 21 geburt okay ich habe nur ein
paar karten geschenkt bekommen also das
ist eigentlich besser als ein ferrari no
umbrella dem macbook pro logic
schiebeleiter und der prader lederschuhe
oh mein gott verpiss dich tigger what
else would you were to school und dieser
scheiß haken allein ich weiß nicht wie
teuer der genau ist aber ich weiß es der
von cartier ist und dann locker auch
irgendwie 10.000 euro also ja menschen
nicht gesund ziemlich abstoßen lommel
weekend ich mich am liebsten umbringen
ein crashtest driving bis also er hat
den aston martin gecrasht und muss jetzt
leider gottes in einem bentley rumfahren
es tut mir leid dass hier schon wieder
knatsch durch mal auf aber da könnte ich
kotzen wenn ich so was wäre ein wanted
yellow parents sagt ja
oder redet something to level magica wie
soll ein stuhl auf rollen überhaupt will
die präsenz newsletter blogs vdk ja ich
spiele ja auch immer mit alten iphones
have to drive myself in des kit und das
ist ein porsche schlüssel only what good
enough hashtag rich spitzen gegen so
eine wasserflasche mit goldenen
stückchen und blinken teilen drauf
dollar
das ist immer noch stinknormales wasser
das nächste rich hat einfach zwei uhren
an seinem arm und ihm fällt nichts
besseres ein als die caption when your
wrist ways you down wahrscheinlich sind
deine eltern nicht zu finden mit ready
for my holiday und ein typ der nackt
zugedeckt ist mit geld alles klappt trip
to the apple server 4
ja ich mein ipad hat nicht gereicht zwei
jahren nicht gereicht heißt ja auch dort
zu wenig vier braucht man definitiv
hätte destroy idiot iphone 4s und die
spielen einfach billard mit einer
champagnerflasche rechts ist ein gumball
3000 schlüsselanhänger und er hat eine
rolex an und ja da möchte ich eigentlich
wirklich am liebsten auf den tisch kommt
hey gestik und es sind 500 euro scheine
in einer taschentücher packung
ich würde dich gern beleidigen aber dann
wäre das video nicht werbe freundlich
und allerdings sind doch schon zum
letzten ritt foto das ich für uns heute
hier raus gesucht habe und zwar ist es
tatsächlich erreichte jugendliche der
welt das ist er hier
ich weiß wie er heißt aber ich kann
seinen namen nicht richtig aussprechen
aber ihr seht ja schon das ist ein
ferrari in louis vitton supreme gerappt
er selbst hat nur louis vitton ursachen
an er zu prim sachen an also glückwunsch
alles selbst erarbeitet anders stelle
sich das heutige jetzt allerdings auch
beenden meine lieben freunde wenn euch
meine reaktion auf diese widgets mal
wieder gefallen hat würde ich mich sehr
über einen daumen hoch von euch unter
dem video freund schreibt ihr zu legen
wenn wir uns in die kommentare
ob ich demnächst nochmal auf kritik
reagieren sondern abonniert main kanal
falls sie noch kein teil der luxus sei
das ist kostenlos und verpasst keine
videos mehr und morgen um 15 uhr
launchen neue klamotten im luca shop
zwei neue moodysson ein neues kissen ich
würde mich sehr freuen wenn ihr da mal
vorbeischauen würde aber jetzt kommt das
auto
[Musik]
ein